here's what we gonna do we're going to
tackle again another quadratic equation
and we're gonna draw it but we're gonna
take a different approach to it one that
will simplify some of the things that
were messy and gross before okay
so let's begin the first thing I want
you to observe is there's a fundamental
diversity in this and the vast majority
of the quadratics that you do with and
has to do with this minus sign right you
see how it's attached to the x squared
so this is gonna change dramatically to
shape that parabola what's the
difference yeah it's gonna be facing
down concave down is the way we say it
rather than concave up so you're looking
for this kind of shape and then we're
gonna have to get the rest of the
features out of that okay now what we
can do here to make things easier for us
is we could you know we can throw in
minus B on to a into this we could
search there's all the usual things but
I want to show you another method for
doing that okay here's the first step
see that minus sign right it kind of
attaches to everything right it makes
the entire parabola face down okay so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take
that minus sign out of the running
like just ignore it as something we have
to worry about and say okay let's put
some brackets here and say x squared if
I've taken a minus sign out everything
else will switch inside do you agree
okay so this guy's gonna become minus 4x
and then there's a most fun okay very
good
now at this point that thing inside the
brackets I asked you to think about how
you would factorize this is there a
number you can think of or pair of
numbers and they they add to this
multiplied to that minus 1 and minus 4/5
and minus
so many options here right okay I'm
gonna write down some things that I hear
you say I can I heard it 4-1 I heard
five and one I heard two and three just
for the loss minus 5 and minus one minus
five plus minus five plus one did I miss
any options just get out okay um do any
of these work don't worry we have
everyone's options here and I'm pretty
confident to say I don't think any of
these work too bad they don't work what
does that mean okay so some of us are
saying okay my next thing that I should
do is launch into the formula
you totally can if that's what you
wanted to do okay but there's an even
bigger problem there's a bigger problem
right I want you to think about this
particular equation right either
particular a and B and see that I've got
and I want you to tell me about this guy
you remember this is an abbreviation
this is an abbreviation for the
discriminant right and the discriminant
we know of course it's the thing
underneath the square root
it's b squared minus 4ac what's B
squared in this case B squared in this
case will be 16 minus 4ac in this case
will be minus 4a see you care with that
which i think is minus 20 now I don't
even need to know what that's equal to
do you say what I mean by or do you see
how before we say oh I don't care at the
discriminant it's an extra thing you
have to work out I don't even need to
know its exact value to know forget
forget all of this like we were all like
wondering like oh I wonder what the
factorization is we don't even need to
search for a factorization because this
tells us there isn't one does that make
sense okay
so you're not going to find roots of
this thing this does not have
x-intercepts right so we still want to
find all that other stuff we mentioned
before that we could use complainers
sorry we could use the axis of symmetry
but instead I want to call in some
knowledge that we didn't use in period
zero at all which is completing the
square so I'm going to rewrite this
thing here
right and I'd like you to have a look at
what I've got here and what you would do
to this if you were to complete the
square there's a thing that we usually
think about adding on and it's a it's a
number here and we have to sort of look
at something in here to work out what
number we should add on hmm
I'll give you a clue I'll give you a
clue it has to do with this number what
are you going to do we're going to have
a coefficient it's the coefficient of x
have it and then square it so when I
have this I get negative 2 when I square
it I get 4 okay now see what I've just
written now number one it's incomplete I
still got more stuff to write but number
two what I've written there is a square
okay so that's useful to me right I can
factorize it nice and neatly
I can't factorize that but this I can
now I said it's incomplete
I just wrote plus four but that's not
what this says right what could I write
here to make it equal to what I wrote
here ya go okay so I could do minus 4
and that would cancel with this right
and then I could write the plus 5 that I
had before that would totally work
there's an even easier thing there's
more directly and get there yeah I've
got 5 and I wrote for the difference is
1 right like so are you okay with that
like these lines are now complete and
the same okay all right now women do
with this well what I wrote down these
first three terms here remember I said
oh those are a square those are really
nice race and if aquestion sorry you're
talking about this line here yeah yep so
yes isn't that what I did
that's that's what you asked me to do
right you asked me to get four plus one
the reason why it's four plus one and
not for example two plus three or some
other combination right is because I
wanted the four by having and squaring
this that's why I know plus four plus
one is the thing to write Hera had I
written plus two plus three it would
still be true it just wouldn't be useful
like because then it's not a square I
can't factorize does that make sense so
I think I have done what you're asking
but I had to know what I was going to
put in here how was gonna break five up
okay now this is the thing I wanted it's
a square see how this plus one is here
and there's a minus sign all the way at
the front so I'm gonna write that as
minus one it's outside the brackets
there you okay with that
yes Justin okay let's have a look see
this plus one it's inside the brackets
but everything inside the brackets has a
minus sign attached to it do you hear
that yeah are you following with me yeah
okay you guys with me you okay all right
so the whole point in me doing this
weird thing and writing it in this way
we're so that I could write it as a
square this thing is something squared
what is it square X plus two - right
it's it's that guy there this guy is
always positive right because it gets
squared but this guy tells us the same
yeah there's a minus one so this is what
I've got
okay now you might think like well
what's the point of that okay why is
this useful I can actually read off the
axis of symmetry and the vertex
immediately just from the way this is
written no other formula is required
okay how am I going to do this let's
think about it beside where you've got
this can I ask you to draw for me one
two three four small sets of axes for
small sets of axes just beside here can
you do that for me
I think it's four okay here's what we
got so these are fairly small and fairly
messy they're going to be used by us as
thinking tools okay and then we're going
to do like a proper one and we'll make
that one big okay now this guy here is
we know it's going to be a problem but
we want to use the way that it's been
written to try and work out what kind of
a parabola
it is so here's what I want to do on the
first set of axes okay we're gonna draw
this like so okay this is just a regular
old y equals x squared parabola y equals
x squared okay now we then change it in
a bunch of ways right you can see all of
these bits and pieces they all make
minor adjustments to this same parabola
right sorry that's a bit bad it should
go right through the origin okay now the
first thing is right at the beginning
you told me without doing any like
calculations or manipulation you Tommy
was face down right where in the
equation do I get the fact that it's
face down yeah it's that it's that minus
at the front right do you agree with
that so I'm gonna say okay well this guy
if I turned it upside down right that
would be y equals minus x squared I've
flipped it vertically okay